Okay, look down at this playing bar… it's
going forward right?
Time moves forward.
Why is that?
This new theory is going to bend your mind,
seriously.
My roommate back in DC could say anything
backwards, you could say something to her,
anything at all, and she could say it back
to you backwards.
Try saying the alphabet backwards, or sing
a Beatles song, or your own name!
Mirror images, backwards things… they are
hard enough to wrap our brains around… but
what about a whole mirror universe?
Literally everything in ours, mirrored.
That's the new theory put forth by physics
to explain time's onward march.
We're not the only universe at this party.
When you look at all the major theories of
physics, Newton's gravitation, Einstein's
relativity, they all only work if time can
go both forward, and backward.
But as we look at it, time is only going one
direction.
Physicists call it, the "arrow of time."
It goes in one direction because the second
law of thermodynamics says as the universe
ages, more entropy is introduced and we measure
time by how much entropy there was before,
versus now.
There's more now, there's always more now.
Entropy, by the way, is hard to define.
But in a roundabout way, it’s like disorder.
See, just after the big bang happened, the
universe was a consistent soup of particles,
and slowly they spread and coalesced into
galaxies, solar systems, planets and so on,
adding entropy.
But, a new study in Physical Review Letters
is challenging this whole idea of thermodynamics
and entropy driving time.
Their findings suggest time is driven, not
by entropy, but by gravity!
They tested this by creating a computer simulation
that ran from the big bang onward and got
a surprising result.
There isn't just ONE direction time can flow.
Their simulated universe was EXTREMELY simple,
it had only 1,000 particles and used Newtonian
physics.
In the simulation, the Big Bang created TWO
universes mirroring each other -- and the
arrow of time flows in opposite directions
in each universe!
Time flowing both ways aligns with other theories,
but it's pretty shocking to think there might
be another universe mirroring ours.
Okay, so if this is true, and as always more
research is needed -- then the arrow of time
in the MIRROR universe is flowing backward
relative to OUR arrow of time, but not for
THEM.
The perception of time is relative, so whomever
lives in the mirrorverse sees their arrow
of time moving "forward."
The cool questions involve what if we could
GO to that universe, would we see them aging
backward?
What about the multiverse, are there infinitely
many mirrorverses in those parallel to us
too?
What's it all MEAN!!?!?!
I know, this is heavy, doc.
There's nothing wrong with the universe's
gravitational pull, and time IS relative,
but… wow.
What if WE'RE THE TWIN!
What if they discovered this long ago and
WE'RE the mirror!
What if in that other universe they're looking
back toward us saying, look at THOSE guys,
amirite?!
Physics gets me so loopy… i love it.
Can you wrap your head around this?
Any smart people out there have more explanations?
Sprew your brain-thoughts down in the comment
corrall.